what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we have our first
initial reviews of moon night in a
select handful of big media companies
out there were chosen to receive an
early early screening of the film i say
this because normal press including
myself gets to see it tomorrow so i'll
be sure to do a video letting you know
what i personally think but some got to
see it pretty dang early and we have
their initial reactions here that i'm
going to go over and it sounds like
we're in for a pretty big treat with
moon knight it sounds like it's going to
be very very different than anything
that we've really seen before in the mcu
and for those of you who were really
hoping for that darker side of the mcu
with moon knight it sounds like we are
indeed going to be getting it so let's
jump into these reviews and see what
people are saying and of course if you
love marvel and the mcu be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu videos this first one
is coming from saab or saab astley over
at collider and they say moon knight is
a brilliantly bonkers dark globe
trotting adventure that's already off to
a pretty great start but they continue
to say this is marvel's trippy national
treasure oscar isaac is the best
addition to the mcu since robert downey
jr entwining torment and humor into a
morally ambiguous cipher mark spectre is
a whole new caliber of hero now this is
a pretty dang good review and initial
reaction to compare somebody to robert
downey jr the father of it all iron man
who started it all that's pretty big now
i love oscar isaac i don't doubt that
he's going to smash it out of the park
but that is still a pretty big praise
right there but collider isn't the only
people who were impressed ashanti umkar
over at bbc states moon knight is
dazzling oscar isaac is a revelation put
on your disney plus uk watch list for
30th of march 2022. relish the music of
hashem nazum and si mei callumway
bringing her effortless flair to the
screen so some more big praise for oscar
isaac they specifically say he is a
revelation and that moon knight is
dazzling so far these reviews definitely
caught my attention but this next one
isn't so over the top like these others
this is from emily murray from xavi and
she says delivering lots of indiana
jones style archaeology action just swap
out the whip for a cape and oscar
isaac's great turn in the lead role moon
night is plenty of fun it's not as
bonkers as i hoped for but a later
episode hints much more of that is
coming now i believe and i should have
stated this in the beginning that these
critics have seen the first four
episodes of moon night that's a lot of
episodes i don't know how many i'll
personally get i just know i get them
tomorrow but they've seen a good amount
of this series now and even though this
review says it's not as bonkers as she
hoped for that still doesn't mean that
it wasn't really good she still praised
oscar isaac for the lead role and even
compared it to indiana jones which of
course is a win however a lot of the
other reviews are really really good
let's go over to tom power from
techradar and he had a lot to say here
he says it's unlike anything you've seen
from marvel before i'd go as far as to
say and i don't say this lightly it's
the best mcu tv show ever moon knight is
the beneficiary of being completely
untethered from every other mcu project
without those connections wayne if
that's the right word to use it down it
has a freedom to do whatever it wants
and oh boy does it the opening episode
is structured in such a way that but for
the marvel logo at the start you
wouldn't think it's an mcu tv series the
way it's edited
how its narrative plays out isaac's
mesmeric fully present performance
honestly is top tier tv i'll save the
rest for my review there are a couple of
tiny little things there about it just
to put that out there but moon knight is
worth the wait again a review a great
review about moon knight with really
high praise to the series now this one i
really like because it talks about how
different moon knight is from all of the
other mcu projects i've heard a lot of
people and seen a lot of comments in the
comic section talking about how marvel
is releasing so much stuff right now and
while some fans like myself may
absolutely just love that and watch
everything that comes out some might
have to pick and choose what they watch
and it sounds like moon night is just
going to be completely different than
anything we've seen before so i suggest
everybody watching this now some of
these critics have actually mentioned
how weird and actually said the word
horror in their review which i know a
lot of people are going to like tom
percival from bbc radio says had a lot
of fun with moon knight it started weird
and only seems to be getting weirder a
good blend of horror action and humor
plus he has a great cape it's
interesting that he uses the words weird
horror action and humor in the same
paragraph but that's actually kind of
something that i wanted from moon knight
it's kind of a psychological thriller
which i'm actually really excited for
but the fact that it still has some
humor into it is obviously really good
as well the university film review says
moon knight is fantastic and oscar isaac
is exceptional as the tormented mark
spectre this is the marvel show everyone
is going to be talking about completely
bonkers that leads with a haunting
adventure marvel studios has knocked it
out of the park with its best show yet
so a few people have called it bonkers
and weird and now a couple of reviews
have said that it's marvel's best show
yet now right now as it stands loki is
my favorite show followed closely by one
division but based off of these reviews
i am wondering if it's going to stay
that way if my top two are gonna stay
that way after seeing moon night let's
go over to david opie from digital spy
he says i've watched the first four moon
night episodes and i'm as divided by the
show as mark spector himself when it
works it's a wildly original mcu entry
with flashes of greatness but some of
the sillier aspects detract from the
horror die hard comic fans might not
enjoy it as much as newcomers and
honestly that is something that i think
every mcu film or show has had to deal
with because they obviously don't just
copy the comics heck in the miss marvel
trailer yesterday they completely
changed up her powers and that could
piss some people off instead of her
being exposed to the terrigen miss she
gets a bracelet that seemingly gives her
her powers that is completely different
than the comics but if everything went
exactly how it went in the comics we
would already know what would happen and
we'd already know what to expect now
this review does mention the horror
aspect as well however he says that
there are sillier sides that do detract
from that horror aspect now keep in mind
it's kind of like doctor strange the
multiverse of madness yes it's supposed
to be the first horror film in the mcu
but it is still pg-13 and it is still a
marvel slash disney movie the same goes
for moon knight sounds like it's going
to be weird going to be trippy have a
horror aspect to it but it's still going
to be a marvel studios project on disney
plus so don't expect it to be like some
rated r horror film the last review
we'll go over here is from david c james
over at games freezer and he says moon
knight is a very weird show with no
obvious connections to the rest of the
mcu but is all the better for it oscar
isaac rivaling tom hardy for best
regular guy taunted by deep voice
monster that lives in his head
performance another big comparison there
comparing oscar isaac's performance to
tom hardy's as venom and again we get a
mention of how weird it is and how it
doesn't have really any connections to
the mcu now of course i do ultimately
think that they're going to connect moon
knight to the mcu by the end of it i
actually do think moon knight is going
to go on to become an avenger but it
does seem like this is kind of not
necessarily an experiment but
essentially an experiment they're taking
it a very different direction than
anything they've ever done before but i
say it's not an experiment because kevin
feige does everything pretty perfectly
so this could be the future of where
marvel studios is going doing one-off
projects that don't necessarily focus on
that mcu connection but of course are
connected to the mcu so these reviews
seem to be pretty dang good what do you
think about them are you excited for
moon knight and of course once i watch
all of the episodes that i get tomorrow
i'll be sure to give you my initial
thoughts as well and i'm also going to
the premiere on tuesday so i'll probably
vlog that as well but in the meantime
what do you think of these reactions are
you excited for moon knight let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe if you want more marvel videos
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof